>> PRESIDENT BIDEN REFUSES TO
TELL MERPS KEY DETAILS ABOUT THE
PIPELINE HACK THAT COULD LEAD TO
IT HAPPENING AGAIN.
THOSE CRIPPLING GAS SHORTAGES
ARE GETTING WORSE.
IN SOME PLACES, 80% OF STATIONS
ARE COMPLETELY OUT.
THEN THERE IS BIDEN REFUSING TO
SAY IF HE KNEW ABOUT COLONIAL
PIPELINE PAYING RANSOM TO THE
HACKERS.
FOR YEARS, DEMOCRATS BLAMED
RUSSIA FOR LITERALLY EVERYTHING,
BIDEN NOW SAYS PUTIN, NOT
INVOLVED.
>> President Biden: WE DO NOT
BELIEVE THE RUSSIAN GOVERNMENT
WAS INVOLVED IN THIS ATTACK, WE
HAVE STRONG REASON TO BELIEVE
THAT THE CRIMINALS WHO DID THE
ATTACK ARE LIVING IN RUSSIA.
THAT IS WHERE IT CAME FROM.
>> Jesse: SO BIDEN, BIDEN
CLEARED THE KREMLIN IN A WEEK,
JUAN.
CASE CLOSED, F.B.I. TOOK CARE OF
IT, HE'S CLEAN.
YOU DON'T THINK THAT IS A LITTLE
STRANGE?
[LAUGHTER]
>> Juan: I WANT TO TALK ABOUT
THAT.
>> Jesse: YOU DON'T THINK THAT
IS STRANGE?
JUANS LE
JOHNSON & J
JUST SAY THIS, JESSE, THIS
CRISIS IS OVER, NO SHORTAGE OF
GAS ANYMORE.
YOU MIGHT BE DEALING WITH
DISTRIBUTION ISSUES.
>> Jesse: PEOPLE CAN'T GET GAS.
>> Juan: I'M TELLING YOU, THERE
IS NO GAS SHORTAGE, MIGHT BE
DISTRIBUTIO
DISTRIBUTION.
ALL THIS ALARMIST TALK --
>> Jesse: OKAY, SEMANTICS.
>> Juan: OKAY, AS FAR AS BIDEN
AND THIS HACKING.
TO ME, WHAT YOU GOT IS A CRIME
SYNDICATE OPERATING OUT OF
RUSSIA AND WE DON'T KNOW, OUR
INTELLIGENCE PEOPLE ARE UNABLE
TO ASCERTAIN FOR SURE IT WAS
SOMETHING DONE BY PUTIN OR AT
PUTIN'S REQUEST.
>> Jesse: WHY DID THEY CLEAR
HIM?
>> Juan: THEY DIDN'T CLEAR HIM,
THEY SAID THEY DON'T KNOW, THEY
DON'T KNOW THAT PUTIN WAS
RESPONSIBLE AT THIS POINT.
I THINK RATHER THAN ACT IN A
RASH MANNER, THERE IS NO
PERSONALITY TO THINKING
STRATEGICALLY, JESSE, WE SAID
THIS YESTERDAY, THIS AMOUNT OF
WAR AGAINST US AND IF WE ARE
ACTING STRATEGICALLY AS IN WAR,
WE HAVE TO ANTICIPATE THE NEXT
STEP.
ACTING RATIONALLY, YEAH, WE'RE
GOING TO MAKE A SHOW OF BRAVADO
IS FOOLISH.
>> Jesse: ALL RIGHT.
WELL, MARTHA, AFTER HILLARY WAS
EMBARRASSED BECAUSE A FEW
E-MAILS CAME OUT SHE WAS WORRIED
ABOUT A BIMBO ERUPTION IN 2016,
DEMOCRATS WANTED TO START WORLD
WAR III WITH RUSSIANS.
NOW PUTIN IS INNOCENT , NO
EVIDENCE OF ANYTHING, THAT IS
CONVENIENT.
>> Martha: IT IS CONVENIENT AND
JUAN TOUCHED ON SOMETHING.
WE CAN'T FIGHT THE LAST WAR, WE
HAVE TO FIGHT THE NEXT WAR.
WHETHER OR NOT PUTIN IS DIRECTLY
INVOLVED, THERE HAD TO HAVE BEEN
A TACET APPROVAL OF THIS, THAT
IS THE WAY THINGS WORK IN THE
SOVIET UNION, EVEN IF AT THE
CORPORATE LEVEL.
BAD ACTORS AROUND THE GLOBE LOOK
AT THIS EVENT AND THEY KNOW THEY
CAN CRIPPLE A THIRD OF THE
UNITED STATES BY HACKING INTO
OUR ENERGY SYSTEMS.
WE HAVE TO BE READY TO FIGHT
CYBER WARFARE, EVEN VIRAL
WARFARE, NOW WHETHER OR NOT
THERE WAS MALINTENT ON WHAT
HAPPENED WITH THIS VIRUS
ESCAPING, LOOK AT THE IMPACT.
THAT IS ANOTHER THING BAD ACTORS
WATCH COSILY.
LOOK AT DIRECT ENERGY ATTACKS
THAT AMERICAN OFFICERS HAVE
SUFFERED IN CUBA, RUSSIA, CHINA.
WE CAN'T SQUABEL OVER WHETHER OR
NOT THERE WAS DIRECT LINK TO
PUTIN, WE NEED TO UNDERSTAND
THIS IS FUTURE OF WARFARE AND WE
NEED TO BE IN FRONT OF IT.
WE CANNOT SIT BACK AND SAY, THAT
IS OVER, WHOA, THAT WENT OKAY,
WE'RE DONE WITH THAT.
>> Jesse: WILL CAIN, HE WAS
ASKED ABOUT RANSOM AND HE SAID
NO COMMENT, THAT SHOWS ME HE
SIGNED OFF ON RANSOM TO RUSSIAN
ATTACKERS.
WHAT DOES THAT SAY?
>> Will: A BAD ONE.
WE DON'T PAY RANSOM, WHY?
IT BEGS MORE OF THAT ATTENTION.
I LIKE YOUR POINT, JESSE, RUSSIA
HAS BEEN GUILTY OF EVERYTHING
UNDER THE SUN, BUT NOW THEY ARE
INNOCENT  IN A COUPLE DAY'S
TIME.
NOTHING HAPPENS IN RUSSIA, THIS
TYPE OF THING DOESN'T HAPPEN IN
RUSSIA WITHOUT PUTIN'S
KNOWLEDGE.
HACKERS ARE OFTEN OFF-DUTY STATE
ACTORS.
I WANT TO INDULGE THE SEMANTIC
BATTLE FOR A SECOND.
CHILD CARE, SYSTEMIC RACISM IS
INFRASTRUCTURE, CAN WE SUBMIT
PIPELINES NEED TO BE PROTECTED,
THAT IS INFRASTRUCTURE, MAYBE
INVEST IN SECURING NO CYBER
ATTACK IF WE CALL IT
INFRASTRUCTURE, WHICH IT IS.
>> Jesse: KENNEDY, IT WAS
INTERESTING THAT THE F.B.I.,
WITH TRUMP, IT WAS GUILTY UNTIL
PROVEN INNOCENT , WITH PUTIN, HE
IS INNOCENT  UNTIL PROVEN
GUILTY.
>> Kennedy: AND THE F.B.I. STILL
VERY GUILTY OF MANY OMISSIONS AS
THEY WERE IN SOME OF THE REPORTS
WE SAW AFTER THE RUSSIAN
COLLUSION SPECIAL INVESTIGATION.
BUT, WILL IS ABSOLUTELY RIGHT
BECAUSE HERE WE HAVE NOT ONLY
CRITICAL INFRASTRUCTURE, WHICH
THAT NOW NEEDS TO BE BUMPED TO
THE TOP OF THE LIST FOR
INFRASTRUCTURE LEGISLATION AND
ABOUT 70% OF IT NEEDS TO GO AWAY
THAT IS NOT ACTUAL
INFRASTRUCTURE AND NOW WE CAN
USE BIG WORDS LIKE BIG PEOPLE
AND TALK ABOUT WHAT
INFRASTRUCTURE REALLY IS.
AND IT IS NOT JUST PIPELINES
THAT HAVE TO BE PROTECTED.
WE HAVE TO PROTECT SATELLITES
AND POWER GRIDS AND DIFFERENT
WAYS WE GET AND USE ENERGY IN
THIS COUNTRY.
IT IS NOT HARD TO THINK HOW WE
COULD BE COMPLETELY PARALYZED,
ESPECIALLY WHEN WE ARE
INCENTIVIZING THIS KIND OF
BEHAVIOR.
SO YES, I DON'T TRUST THE
F.B.I., I DON'T TRUST THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT.
THIS IS WHY I'M A LIBERTARIAN,
THEY HAVE WRONG PRIORITIES AND
USUALLY GET EVERYTHING WRONG
WHEN THEY TRY TO GO BIG.
>> Jesse: I THINK IF PUTIN
HACKED THE SOLAR GRID, BIDEN
WOULD HAVE BEEN PRETT